my name is Tommy Dolan and I'm the
weapons master on HBO Game of Thrones
everyone tells me to call this job in
the world and they say it's the one with
the biggest headache for them now it's
cool but mainly down to myself what did
looking design is and the feel of all
the weaponry and and again I've never I
never looked and never chase up you
which that George had in books because I
didn't want to be persuaded by his feel
or his interpretation or like my feel
about my interpretation of Washington
what it is how did you make beric
Dondarrion
claiming that the combination of a
between ourselves and the special
effects team because obviously I made
them design the original one which is
quite a basic stories not the nothing
fancy about us it's a very fun but then
obviously the special effects then had
to come up with a procedural of lighting
it so it made a an internal gas system
into a hollow sword and then we just
applied all the cross guards of Hamelin
handles so they would make a gastrique
and then would make a basis or that was
impregnated which with a little icing
liquid that that could be yes from my
flame so it'll keep life for those you
know half a minute
and I think we're simple enough the
physical one that they fought with but
the gas one of the very intricate this
week no you design to and to turn it off
but they did they the effective is very
very good job good lad it's an old cape
was was it with with the tricky one who
can making sure that it looks like what
are the mullahs and then dealing using
tools like Swarovski crystals
what is labeled with with a nice one it
was on those things were obviously Jim
she's a very young girl at that stage I
think nothing made she was only like 12
partying and she was a very petite girl
so we knew that the weapon would have to
be of some sort of foil and do you know
that kind of scenario where being an
evil it just it was exactly what the
name said it looks like a needle but
quite a natural small little swords and
it hasn't changed for horror hasn't
changed at all
as in you know obviously she's growing
up
not a lot but she's grown up so the
software just kept winner did the same
we've never had to play with him she was
always very good with us considered that
she fights fights left-hander so she is
actually right-handed there dangerous
enough
at the same time immunity our heroines
for example will be a pattern wow there
will be steel blades we never fight with
them but we'd always have them for tea
the hero fail and error look he we
always then make we make an aluminium
version of the blade we'll make a bamboo
version and we'll make a rubber version
so we have all the comparables that will
be safe
so anybody fights with the bamboo one
bamboo the rubber on rubber would be
aluminium and aluminium and never we
never mix and match the different blades
there are so many different looks and
styles that were brought into details
absolutely and 15 tailors and different
types depending on what they what the
weapon would be with a principle weapon
you'd have a couple of couple of hero
once you have for apply of fighting
swords and then again six or eight
safety swords so make sure that
everybody's a it's a fun session so I
sort of just to ride horses that we have
rubber scabbard over rubber swords so
everything works well some of writers
are very strong or what happens is that
to just keep hammering hammering so hard
they suddenly realize if they have
bamboo that they again they can move
faster and with some some of our
training regimes for example we had that
part and Brienne fighting that's an area
where we had to make sure there's a bit
of bamboo just going to slow down and
take the power away from Brienne it's
just a grind on the strong girl and puts
a lot of power into it so we just had to
try and find a way of pulling that power
back a little bit the front wooden
aluminium swords or even according the
wooden sword but that's gonna really hit
hard with us onto another sword or in
your fight with a bamboo you'll find us
less is more with them so actually don't
slow them down a bit with the power I
would imagine
in the battle the bastards there's a
fairness ordinance and that was a lot of
robot there's none of that in that one
it will be the best season ever a little
the nothing would surpass this I woke my
grandmother I think I think you'll wake
up a few ancestors this year that's uh
next year when it comes out it does only
your granny